the 16 inch MacBook Pro is one of the
most highly anticipated Apple products
in years and based on our testing of
this new machine specifically twelve
videos so far covering the 16 inch
macbook pro we truly believe that this
is the best value macbook that's ever
been made let me explain why before we
get into the performance cooling
improvements and pricing I want to first
point out the new features that really
make it stand out compared to the old
15-inch model now you may have noticed
that I just called the 15 inch model old
which it's not since the latest update
was released just six months ago while
I'll explain why I said that in just a
minute the beauty of the 16 inch macbook
pro is that it offers an excellent
package of updated features and
performance at the base price showing
that yes Apple has finally started
listening we asked for better cooling we
got it we asked for a larger battery we
got it thinner bezels a better keyboard
a physical Escape key a more powerful
charger and 512 gigabytes of base
storage Apple gave us what we asked for
and at the same base price as before
which a lot of people weren't expecting
they even threw in things we didn't even
ask for like the updated speakers
updated microphones up to a massive 64
gigabytes of RAM and an insane 8
terabytes of storage which is overkill
for most people and they even allow you
to get the best graphics option while
configuring from the base model instead
of forcing you to start with a
higher-end $2800 model like they did
with the 15-inch MacBook Pro Apple
didn't have to do any of that but they
did and we the consumers are benefitting
from it because the 16 inch macbook pro
is an excellent deal yes it's a bit
larger and heavier than the 15-inch
model but after a month of use the 6
inch pro starts to feel no different in
size you honestly just get used to it
ask for the keyboard we've been using it
for almost a month and we've yet to have
any reliability issues at all nor have
we heard of anybody else having issues
either and on top of that it feels
better as well you get more key travel
along with a nice springy feedback that
makes in my opinion the best Mac board
keyboard yet yes even better the
the one on the 2015 MacBook Pro which we
did test and compare it to this new
keyboard and as a plus that physical
Escape key is a lot more convenient to
use the display hasn't really changed
apart from the slightly larger size but
Apple has also slimmed down the bezels
especially at the top and the difference
is actually significant it looks quite a
bit more immersive and modern for the
speakers the 16 inch macbook pro packs a
set of three speakers on each side and
it's actually the perfect setup because
each speaker is fully dedicated to a
certain sound frequency range one
speaker for the high notes one for the
mid tones and one just for bass this
means that a single speaker doesn't have
to produce two different frequency
ranges at the same time so there's no
clashing or blending of tones and for
that same reason vocals are incredibly
clear and you can easily hear every
single instrument and note within a song
compared to previous models where it can
sound muffled or tinny at max volume the
only downside is that the speaker's got
a little bit quieter than the 15-inch
but the quality is definitely worth the
trade-off
[Music]
[Music]
the 16 inch MacBook Pro also has
upgraded microphones the Apple calls
studio quality now I wouldn't
necessarily say that is good enough to
replace a studio microphone but it's
actually good enough for content
creators who are just starting out and
don't want to invest in a dedicated
microphone just yet
my big issue with it is that we still
get the old 720p webcam which looks
horrendous in comparison to the better
microphone quality now let's get into
the good stuff performance starting with
the processor when Apple first added the
six core option to the MacBook Pro the
cooling system was so limiting that
paying an extra $400 for the I nine
processor only got you around two
percent more real-world performance
under load but since then Apple and
Intel have been working on optimizations
and along with a new thicker body and
improved cooling on the 16 inch MacBook
Pro the base model with the 2.6
gigahertz i7 processor now actually
outperforms the best 2.9 gigahertz six
core I nine processor from the 2018 the
15-inch MacBook Pro which is very
impressive the only downside with a
better cooling system is that it's a
little bit louder than before around one
to two decibels louder but the fan noise
isn't as high-pitched as before so it's
not too bad and definitely worth the
better cooling we tested quite a few
things with the base model and we found
that it's fast enough for most people
for video editing the six core base
model was surprisingly not that much
slower than the eight core model that
also came with the best graphics and 32
gigabytes of RAM for a total price of
$3,500 in a couple of the tests the
better spec model did much better for
mainly one reason which I'll get into in
just a second but overall the base model
was able to handle video editing
extremely well considering the price we
then tested photo editing in Lightroom
and Photoshop in the base model yet
again handled them perfectly fine
exposure and color adjustments were
instant brushes were smooth and
responsive zooming was super quick and
the Spot Healing Brush worked instantly
now you might be thinking why not
upgrade to the eight core processor yes
the cooling has been
so now the 8-core can run at higher
clock speeds but so can the six core
sure you can get the eight core if you
have the extra money but I actually
think the base six core processor is now
fast enough for most people and that's
due to one very important recent change
in the software world graphics
performance has recently been improving
quicker than processor performance so
certain productivity apps like Final Cut
Pro 10 in various Adobe apps like
Lightroom Photoshop and Premiere Pro
have all recently been updated to use
more graphics power than ever before
therefore leaving less work for the
processor to have to deal with in what's
great about the 16 inch MacBook Pro is
that it packs
AMD's brand-new Navi seven nanometer
graphics chips which are a massive
improvement over the previous graphics
and the 15-inch MacBook Pro even the
base graphics and the sixteen inch is
almost as powerful as the top spec Vega
20 graphics option in the 15 and in a
lot of our tests the base 5300 M
graphics on the 16 inch performed quite
close to the best 5500 M 8 gigabyte
graphics option being only a bit slower
for common 4k video editing as well as
4.5 K red raw editing and for gaming the
base model performed basically the same
as the higher-end model getting the same
70 FPS average and call of duty modern
warfare which is very impressive now
there were two specific tests where the
better graphics model performed much
better in the blender benchmark it
finished almost twice as fast as the
base model and in our five minute 8k
raat export test it finished almost four
times as fast and it did it for mainly
one reason it's packing eight gigabytes
of video memory and those specific tests
were completely maxing it out so the
four gigabytes of vram on the base model
was a major limitation in those tests
and for those of you doing other things
like programming and music production
the base 6 core processor should be more
than good enough for most of you out
there and for those of you doing work
that is high-end enough to require the
eight core processor you're probably
making enough money from that work to
not even question upgrading the
processor or the RAM but for everyone
else the base 16 inch macbook pro is the
first base model that can handle
wide variety of productivity programs
without having to worry about which
upgrades to buy and what's even more
impressive is that the base model now
gets double the storage at the same
price inacceptable 512 gigabytes which
also runs at incredibly fast transfer
speeds basically as fast as the 2019 Mac
Pro's SSDs we honestly believe that the
base 16 ish MacBook Pro is the go-to
model for most people because the value
you get for the cache is the best we've
ever seen on any MacBook ever
you'll get awesome performance along
with great features like the new
reliable keyboard modernized 16 inch
display and best-in-class speakers now
as far as features we wish Apple would
have included an SD card slot would have
been really nice since it's the most
common storage card used by a lot of
people but Apple chose to stick with for
Thunderbolt 3 ports once again we also
wish it featured face ID upon occasion
but due to the very thin display it
doesn't seem like we're getting that
anytime soon now for those of you who
already have a 2018 or 2019 15-inch
MacBook Pro you honestly won't see much
of a difference in performance
especially if you already have bigger 20
graphics but for everyone else the 16
inch MacBook Pro will definitely be a
big upgrade now with the holiday season
around the corner a lot of the 15-inch
MacBook Pros are now on sale like this
high-end 2019 model that's already a
whole $500 off but while it might be
tempting there's one huge problem with
it
the latest 15-inch model already seems
old even after only one month since the
release of the 16 inch pro that's
permanently replacing it imagine two or
three years down the road when you're
trying to sell your discontinued 15-inch
MacBook Pro while every new model for
the last couple of years has been a 16
inch you're honestly not going to get as
much for it especially since it uses the
butterfly keyboard which a lot of people
believe is faulty that's why the 2019
15-inch pro is a massive 500 dollars off
on Amazon after only six months they
need to sell out of their existing
inventory quickly before people realize
that it actually makes more sense to
just buy the base 16 inch model instead
so to be completely honest we fully
recommend the 16 inch macbook pro
instead of saving some extra cash by
going with the 15-inch and if you're
wanting to spend some extra cash on
upgrades but you're not sure which ones
check out our buyer's guide right over
there as well as our entire 16 inch
macbook pro playlist right there and if
you enjoyed this review tap like and
click the circle above subscribe for our
in-depth testing of the 2019 Mac Pro
coming soon thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]